Humans love meat, steak, fried
chicken, bacon, pork belly,
and sausages are just the best things.
Eating meat has become so trivial that
many people don't consider something a
proper meal if there's no animal involved,
which is pretty amazing since
only a few decades ago meet.
It was a luxury product. Today you
can get a cheeseburger for a dollar.
Paradoxically, meat is pretty much the
most inefficient way of feeding humans.
If we look at it on a global scale,
our meaty diet is literally
eating up the planet.
Why is that and what can we do
about it without giving up steak?
Humans keep a lot of animals for food.
Currently about 23 billion chickens,
1.5 billion cattle and roughly
1 billion and pigs and sheep,
that's a lot of mouths to feed,
so we've transformed earth
into a giant feeding ground.
83% of it's farmland is used for my stock.
For example,
his posture and to farm fodder
crops like corn and soy.
That's 26% of earth's total land area.
If we include the water
we need for these plants,
meat and dairy production accounts for
27% of global fresh water consumption.
Unfortunately, meat production is
like a black hole for resources.
Since animals are living things,
most of their food is used to
keep them alive while they grow.
They're tasty parts only a fraction of
the nutrients from fodder crops and up in
the meat we buy in the
end. Cows, for example,
convert only about 4% of the proteins
and 3% of the calories of the plants we
feed to them into beef.
More than 97% of the
calories are lost to us
to create one kilogram of steak account
needs to eat up to 25 kilos of grain and
uses up to 15,000 liters of water.
Animal products that aren't
guzzling up tons of food,
but they only make up 18% of the calories
humans eat according to projections.
We could nourish an additional 3.5
billion people if we just ate the stuff we
feed to animals to make our favorite
food group even more unsustainable.
About 15% of all greenhouse gas emissions
caused by humans are created by the
meat industry as much as by all ships,
planes,
trucks and cars combined.
And there's another aspect to meet.
It comes from actual living
beings, pigs, cattle and chicken.
A lot love the ones
writing the history books,
but if they were humans would appear as
ramping genocidal maniacs that thrive on
suffering globally.
We kill about 200 million
animals every day,
about 74 billion a year.
This means that every one and a half years
we kill more animals than people have
lived in the entire 200,000
year history of humanity.
One could argue that we're
doing them a favor after all.
They wouldn't exist without us.
We might eat them in the end,
but we also provide food and shelter
and the gift of existence to them
unfortunately were not very nice gods.
A lot of our meat comes
from factory farms,
huge industrial systems that house
thousands of animals and Genea to be as
efficient as possible. They have little
regard for things like quality of life.
Most pigs are raised in gigantic window
less sheds and never get to see the sun
sow's.
Our captain pans too small to turn around
where they give birth to one litter of
piglets after another until it's
their turn to be turned into Bacon.
Dairy cows are forced to breed
continually to ensure their milk supply,
but are separated from their carves
hours after birth to fastener beef cattle
for slaughter.
They're put in feedlots confined pens
where they can't roam and put on weight
more quickly to make it possible to keep
them so tightly together without dying
of diseases.
The majority of antibiotics,
we use our for livestock up to 80% in
the u s which helps in the short term but
also fuels antibiotic resistances,
but the ones that may have got the worst
deal. Our chickens in factory farms,
they're kept in such vast numbers and
so close to each other that they can't
form the social structures
they have in nature,
so they start attacking each other to
stop that. We cut their beaks and clause.
Male chickens are deemed worthless
since they can't lay eggs and are not
suitable for me. Production.
So within minutes after birth,
they're usually gassed and shredded.
In grinders,
several hundred million baby chickens
are killed this way each year.
Even if you had a personal
score to settle with chickens,
how we treat them is beyond broken,
so better buy organic meats where
animals are treated nicely, right?
Organic farming regulations are designed
to drive to animals a minimum of
comfort.
The problem is that organic is an elastic
term according to EU regulations and
organic hen still might share one
square meter of space with five others.
That's a long way off from
happy farmyard chickens.
Farms that sincerely do their
best do exist of course,
but meat is still a business and organic
label is a way to charge more money and
countless scandals have revealed producers
looking for ways to cheat the system.
And while organic meat
might be less cruel,
it needs even more resources than
conventional meat production.
So buying organic is still preferable
but does not grant you moral absolution.
The truth is if suffering,
we're a resource,
we would create billions
of tons of it per year.
The way we treat animals will probably
be one of the things future generations
will look down on in disgust.
While all these things are true,
something else is true to
steak is amazing. Burgers,
other best food, chicken
wings, tastes great. Meet,
satisfies something buried
deep in our lizard brain.
We hardly ever see how our meat is made.
We just eat it and love it.
It creates joy. It brings us together
for family meals and barbecue parties.
Eating meat doesn't make you a bad person.
Not eating meat doesn't
make you a good one.
Life is complicated and so
is the world we've created.
So how should we deal with the fact that
meat is extremely unsustainable and a
sort of horrible torture?
For now,
the easiest option is
opting out more often.
Taking a meat free day per week
already makes a difference.
If you want to eat meat
produced with less suffering,
try to buy from trusted producers
with a good track record,
even if it costs more to make
an impact on the environment.
Go for chicken and pig rather than lamb
and beef as they convert their feed more
efficiently and to beat.
And if you're going to have your steak,
you should eat it to an average American
throws out nearly a pound of food per
day. A lot of which is meet in the
future science could get as clean,
makes various startups have successfully
grown meat and labs and are working on
doing so on a commercial scale.
But solutions like this are
still a few years away for now.
Enjoy a steak but also respect it and
if you can make it something special
again,
we have something else for you that's
also special and tastes even better than
steak.
We get asked a lot how we make our videos.
We thought we just show you could
cause are teamed up with skill share.
Our favorite online tutorial service to
teach you are unique animation style.
We've just released part three of our
animation tutorial series where you can
learn to animate a scene from our videos.
Skillshare is an online learning community
with over 20,000 classes in all kinds
of cool stuff like writing,
illustration and animation
with their premium membership.
You get unlimited access to high quality
classes from skill professionals.
One of them is us, and we also
snagged a special offer for you,
the first 1000 people to use
the link in the description,
get two months of
unlimited access for free.
If you want to learn how we animate
our videos, you can start there today.